It's that time of year when your favorite
series are back — like This Is Us, The Good
Place, Better Things, and even Will & Grace.
But there are also a number of brand new network
and on-demand shows that are sure to blow
you away.
Here's a rundown of the shows that premiered
in Fall of 2017 that you should definitely
make some time for.
The Mayor
The time is right for a new political comedy
to step up and help us temporarily escape
from real-life drama — and ABC's The Mayor
is here to help.
Centering around the charismatic Brandon Michael
Hall's character Courtney Rose — an aspiring
rapper who gets elected mayor after running
for office as a publicity stunt — The Mayor
could potentially be crowned this season's
best new comedy.
It's funny, refreshingly light-hearted, and
optimistic — and it certainly has our vote
of confidence.
Future Man
If Seth Rogen is releasing a project, it should
probably be on your radar.
The well-established funnyman is once again
teaming up with Evan Goldberg to take on the
end of the world — a favorite topic of the
two This is The End creators.
With their show Future Man, Rogen and Goldberg
are looking to stand out from the comedy crowd
with their own patented brand of humor.
In an interview with SYFY Wire, Rogen and
Goldberg said that they prefer very high-stakes
comedy...and Future Man is exactly that.
"People could die at any second.
To us, that's the funniest.
I don't know why, probably because we're sick."
Star Trek: Discovery
As the first new Star Trek show in more than
a decade, Star Trek: Discovery is under some
serious pressure to perform.
Setting the expectations even higher is the
fact that it takes place after Star Trek:
Enterprise and before the original series
of the 1960s, meaning Discovery needs to successfully
maintain continuity if it wants to please
the franchise's hardcore fanbase.
Luckily, fans have tweeted out their positive
reactions, so perhaps all systems are, indeed,
a go.
With the charismatic Sonequa Martin-Green
headlining a cast of almost all new characters,
Discovery should please longtime Trekkies
and newcomers alike.
SMILF
Showtime's hottest new series this fall is
undoubtedly SMILF, about a basketball-playing,
man-chasing South Boston woman who also happens
to be a single mother raising a toddler.
SMILF thrives in its authentic feel, thanks
to writer, producer, director and star Frankie
Shaw, who claims the show is semi-autobiographical.
With Rosie O'Donnell as Shaw's mother and
Nashville's Connie Britton on board, it looks
like Showtime is set to score a big win with
SMILF.
Big Mouth
If adult-themed animated comedies are your
thing, look no further than Netflix's definitely-not-family-friendly
series Big Mouth, which follows two teenagers
in the throes of puberty as they battle hormone
monsters and newfound adolescent interests.
Throw in a star-studded cast — featuring
comedy favorites like Nick Kroll, Maya Rudolph,
John Mulaney, and Jordan Peele, to name a
few — and the fact that Netflix has already
proven itself with adult animated shows, and
Big Mouth is sure to be a home run.
"You have a really big mouth"
"Thank you, I think?"
The Deuce
Can't get enough of James Franco?
Then HBO's new series The Deuce is for you
— featuring the actor in not one but two
leading roles, while also working behind the
scenes as an executive producer and director.
The drama follows twin brothers Vincent and
Frankie Martino, both played by Franco, during
the early days of New York City's porn industry.
The creators of the series have already laid
out their plan of exactly how they want it
to go, with eight episodes per season for
three seasons.
In an interview with Collider, Franco said,
"I think if we pull it off, it will be a really
nice encapsulation of a time and a place."
Young Sheldon
CBS's ultra-popular sitcom The Big Bang Theory
was destined to get a spinoff — and here
it is.
Young Sheldon centers around child genius
Sheldon Cooper, but the similarities stop
there.
Unlike its parent sitcom, Young Sheldon has
no studio audience, and it has a more sentimental,
family-oriented tone.
"How can I be excited when he's gonna be in
the same grade as me?"
"Don't worry Georgie I'm not planning on being
in the 9th grade for very long."
This stylistic change in format works in the
spinoff's favor, as does the standout work
of Iain Armitage as the title character.
Whether you're a fan of The Big Bang Theory
or not, you'll definitely want to give the
more mature Young Sheldon a chance.
Lore
Based on Aaron Mahnke's popular podcast of
the same name, Amazon's Lore is set to dominate
the horror genre this season.
The series' first season will run for six
episodes, with each episode acting as a standalone
horror story, running the gamut from demons
to medical experiments gone wrong.
If frights are your thing, be sure to check
out Lore.
American Vandal
Whether you love or hate true crime documentaries,
you'll certainly get a kick out of Netflix's
self-satirizing spoof American Vandal.
The series lampoons the all-too-familiar genre
by focusing on the crime and punishment of
Dylan Maxwell, a high schooler expelled for
drawing male genitalia across 27 automobiles.
"Because everyone thinks I did it."
"Did what?"
"The d----"
What ensues is an utterly brilliant deconstruction
of everyone's favorite binge-worthy guilty
pleasure…and it's one you definitely won't
want to miss.
The Gifted
Marvel series are always met with anticipation,
and The Gifted is no different.
So far, fans and critics agree — it's definitely
delivering.
The Gifted excels in both its premise — a
mutant family on the run from the Sentinel
Services — and the special effects it uses
for its mutants' powers.
Whether you're an X-men fan or not, The Gifted's
impressive cast will — quite literally — blow
you away.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!